CBS News has learned the maker of
oxycontin is offering to pay billions of
dollars to settle thousands of lawsuits
stemming from the opioid crisis a
government source with knowledge of
these negotiations says Purdue Pharma is
offering between five and six billion
dollars now it comes as we're seeing
newly obtained video of a member of the
Sackler family which owns Purdue Pharma
defend the marketing of its signature
painkiller in a deposition
do you believe produce marketing was
overly aggressive no deeply produced
marketing was appropriate I believe so
our consumer investigative correspondent
that's Anna Werner has been closely
following this story for months now and
I guess the big question is what led to
the release of this video now well so
this video was obtained by Pro Publica
this deposition it was released as part
of a 2015 lawsuit brought against Purdue
Pharma by the state of Kentucky a
lawsuit that was ultimately settled for
more than 20 million dollars as we said
that more than eight hour video
deposition obtained by Pro Publica and
in it dr. Richard Sackler the former
chairman and president of Purdue Pharma
says under oath he does not know how
much the family has made off the sale of
oxycontin now Purdue Pharma is best
known as the developer of oxycontin the
company is facing billions of dollars in
potential liability for its role in the
nation's opioid crisis it's unclear how
much Purdue's owners the Sackler family
would have to pay the company has
released a statement saying it's
prepared to defend itself in court but
says the company has made clear that it
sees little good coming from years of
wasteful litigation and appeals and the
people in communities affected by the
opioid crisis need health now talks of a
potential settlement come two days after
that landmark decision in Oklahoma in
that case a judge ordered pharmaceutical
giant Johnson & Johnson to pay five
hundred seventy two million dollars for
its role in the state's opioid crisis if
you know Anna thank you